like people can smell gang banging other
gang bangers can smell other gang
bangers that's why if they like hit you
up oh where you from like oh man uh
where you who was your mama where you
live where you grew up at like you know
they'll smell out they could tell yeah I
mean I've always uh had always tells me
and I don't know if this is good advice
or bad advice but he said if I ever end
up somewhere and I have a couple of
times where I was getting gas somewhere
and I callede this happened like he
posted it on Instagram cuz I HIIT him
and I was like yo I'm right here am I
good to get something to eat I'm getting
gas and he's like what the [__] are you
doing there yeah but he head would
always say he's like yo if you end up
somewhere and you get banged on just
start acting like real frantic like
you're in the middle of a crazy fight
with your girl and you got lost like man
my bad bro sorry man [__] fighting
with my [__] bro I don't know what the
[__] cuz that's a universal mascul
we all be like man I just got caught
cheating this tripping BR she [__]
had me get out the car my B bro do your
thing yeah yeah man my bad you know
that's what head say it's true it works
it he like just just act like you're in
the middle of a crazy fight with your
girl you don't know where you're at and
you know get on your phone and like it
should be all right yeah yeah yeah now
for the most part it's okay I mean gang
bangers the most underrated part about
gang banging is they're pretty
understanding yeah if they sober if
they're
sober like most that's like hey I about
say that's a pretty general statement
for the world but gang banging it get
worse when you know you drunk because
you get superpowered and people be
charged up yeah like my wife when she
gets mad if she's drunk and mad it's
over it's over another Latina oh yeah
yeah that's Spanish cuss
word Spanish cuss words yeah there's a
lot of Spanish cuss wordss I've been
called um okay so if someone gets your
CD physically and they look at the back
you have obviously you got West Coast
cam you got sugarfree shout out to
sugarfree The Legend and I need you to
help me get connected with him sure I
got you I got you um but then you also
have Samuel Jackson and the Notorious
BIG listed as features yeah yeah yeah um
explain both I just feel like it's
always weird when you looking at a track
list and and somebody voice pop up who
the [__] is that and I just put that
there like um obviously on Spotify I
didn't try to infringe on their
audiences but I wanted people to know
that that voice you hear is going to be
biggie this voice is going to be Mar
Luther King or Samuel Jackson or that's
fair Cedric the Entertainer you also
have um the guy who plays Jesus um in
the music video for slink Johnson yeah
shout out to slink Johnson he did a
really good job on uh Freddy Gibbs album
too he kind of was like a he did one of
the skits on his album uh and he did
great on your music video yeah yeah uh
what's it save something for the [__]
for [__] something for the [__]
for [__] yeah which is um an ODed
to uh it's weird because right there's a
men with
bedazzled anklets that and just just
straight men impeding on women's beauty
standards in the first place completely
top to bottom I tell them all the time
straight man Cyrus my shooter over there
got two earrings in that you know what's
funny that 30 40 years ago that would
have been look FR that 20 years ago
that's normal mhm when I was growing up
my dad used to always tell me if you
have an earring or a certain side of
meant that you were gay yeah oh yeah
like the right side right and if you
have both it's like what girls do yeah
that's true and that that used to be
that way that used to be that way then R
Kelly kicked that down because he had
them things him and AI you know what I'm
saying but no this album in general cuz
you're listen man if y'all don't follow
glasses on Twitter he's one of the most
frustrating entertaining follows ever
there are very few things that I I so me
and you it's funny because I'm getting
ready to redo the whole set and a lot of
my set is going to be dedicated I bought
a doggy style on vinyl the OG vinyl good
that's good and I bought the uh o OG
cassette I've have had three copies of
the C I was a kid that's a good one but
you and I are very aligned with some
hip-hop opinions some very very some and
four out of 10 most of most of the ones
that we're very passionately dug in on
have to do with Snoop and have to do
with doggy style because doggy style is
the most important hip-hop album in my
entire life sure and it's the most it's
the greatest one of all the hip-hop and
I I kind of have like a three album
where I could be like this this is my
goat album right it's Illmatic it's
doggy style probably get rich of Die
Trying in any order that those could be
one two or three on Monday Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday whatever but doggy
sty is the most important in my life
that's fair and in my opinion Snoop Dog
somehow while being the most famous
rapper in the world by far still
underrated he's underrated yes agree how
is this a possibility by the way my
bucket list interview I hit his guy Kev
once a month and I'm like dude I'll go
to the it's my bucket list alltime
interview if I can interview Snoop I
might cry cuz I want to explain to him
me getting doggy style on accident
changed the path of my life but how is
Snoop still
underrated how does that happen well
he's the greatest hip-hop artist of all
time right but if you favor certain
Styles maybe Snoop won't fit that style
so immediately he's from the West so
that's going to immediately take credit
from the the Cornerstone of hip-hop in
New York or the East Coast that's going
to be a Cornerstone issue that he's not
from the right East he's from the West
um his style is like a
oneoff you know what I mean to me is
like a descendant of like short and LL
CJ super smooth you know what I mean but
you can see he's such a hip-hop kid like
First videos you can see the special ed
in his movements how he moved and how
smooth he was um I think the majority of
it
is one he's from the west coast and not
from the East two would probably
be he's
alive he's alive that's real real [__]
you know what I mean he's alive and
that's really important which is even
greater because you look at him now and
he's probably like
still the most
recognizable you know rapper on the
planet no I do say that I say there's
certain artists that if God forbid they
passed away would shoot to the greatest
of all and I I really think that about
Kendrick like I tell people like yeah we
we really kind of don't appreciate
Kendrick like we should cuz if he passed
away tomorrow for whatever reason he's
the goat um he's at least he's at least
like solidified in that conversation in
the same way we talk about p and it's
really dope and I try not to comment on
dot because you know dot is my friend
and somebody I I love to death you guys
have done records together way way
deeper you know I mean this [__] really
my partner but it's like he's also a
generation undermines so I have to to
listen to a lot of younger people tell
me versus me giving my cuz I I have
[__] that I'm looking like you
Scarface I'm saying scar it's like as
much as I love DOD is like Scarface you
know me he raised me do is like well I
would just say cuz like we put biggie in
certain conversations based on two
albums when he was alive we got two
albums from that's them them albums is
[__] that well no those albums are
incredible but what I'm saying is if you
if if you look at just like if something
happened to died it it'd be frantic it
be frantic it it it would probably re it
would probably reshape hip-hop at that
point permanently I think unfortunately
people sometimes when they
leave uh prematurely they get
appreciated more and I think we've seen
that happen a lot of time and time again
over the last decade or or or or their
Spirit can be free to roam about the
cabin yeah cuz I think a lot of times we
don't get into like even with nip right
I always felt like people look at gang
bangers and feel like I can't relate
right even though like you know [__]
is regular human beings but they can't
relate and I think it became so
important for people to to get what he
was on when he passed away cuz it made
him mortal right people really look at
gang banging like like a he-man sport
like oh man if they die I don't care or
you know or they can't die or they did
something to die or they in prison you
know versus some dude just really
running a business and having a problem
and somebody taking his life and I think
there's nothing more human than that so
I think that's what happened with him